في المقابل هناك مبادرات في المنطقه
العربيه تهدف الى تمكين الشباب وتحسين
مستقبلها من بينها مبادره جسور التي تهدف
الى ايجاد فرص للشباب والشبات العاطلين عن
العمل وتزويدا بخدمات لتحسين احتمالات
لتشغيلهم كتحسين مهاراتهم اكتساب مهارات
جديده لتلبيه المتطلبات المتغيره لمستقبل
العمل كما تشكل العباده جسرا بين اصحاب
المصلحه الرئيسيه في القطاع الخاص والشباب
والشابات الموهوبين الباحثين عن فرص عمل
في المنطقه العربيه
من بيروت ينضم الينا المسؤوله في الشؤون
التنميه الاجتماعيه في لجنه الامم المتحده
اقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الغرب اسيا منى فتاح
اهلا بك يسعد صباحك معانا في صباح العربيه
ااا اولا كيف تعالج مبادره جسور الشباب
الذين يبحثون عن عمل ايجاد فرصه
صباح الخير
هي الجسر الفعلي لعبور هؤلاء الشباب من
حاله البطاله وعدم توفر العمل الى الفرص
الحقيقيه سواء بايجاد فرص العمل او في
ايجاد فرص تمكينيه تدريبيه تساعدهم للتحضر
لسوق العمل طيب منى اليوم بالحديث عن ان
العالم وبعض بلدان العالم العربي شيخ بحكم
كونك في الاسكوا هل نتحدث عن صوره قاتمه
يعني عن توقعات متشائمه كيف يبدو المستقبل
الحقيقه هي الصوره نوعا ما قادمه حاليا
بوجود 26 بالمئه من الشباب عاطلين عن
العمل ولا يجدون فرصه في المنطقه العربيه
ولكن بفضل مثل هذه المبادرات وبفضل تكاتف
القطاع الخاص المنظمات الاهليه او
المنظمات الدوليه وكذلك القطاع العام انا
اعتقد ان هؤلاء الشباب سيجدون فرصتهم وحتى
من يشيخون في العمر ايضا سيجدون فرصتهم من
خلال هذه المبادرات او هذه المحاولات
لايجاد فرص للجميع طيب هناك تطبيق ممكن ان
يساعد الشباب على تعزيز فرص فرصها في
ايجاد عمل هل يمكن ان تتحدثين عن اكثر
نعم هو بالفعل هي منصه الكترونيه تعمل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي حيث يمكن للشاب والشابه
الدخول تعبئه استماره بمثابه سيره ذاتيه
تشرح عن مهاراتهم مساواهم التعليمي او حتى
خبراتهم التقنيه والفنيه اليدويه
ومن جهه اخرى يقوم اصحاب الفرس او مقدمه
الفرس ثلاثيه من المؤسسات التي تبحث عن
هؤلاء ايضا بعرض همم هذه الفرص على نفس
المنصه وسيكون الذكاء الاصطناعي بربط
الطرفين العرض والطلب من دون تدخل ولا
واسطه سيتم الربط بين الاثنين بشكل تلقائي
ومباشر كل منهم سيعلم عن الاخر
طيب منى اليوم عندما تشتكي تونس من تهرم
السكاني ماذا يعني ذلك لنشرح لي المشاهدين
انا اربطه بعدم فرص العمل او الفرص
الحقيقيه لشبابنا العربي مما يدفع هؤلاء
للهجره وتلك المنطقه العربيه ونحن لو
ساعدنا هؤلاء على اجاده الفرصه الحقيقيه
وايضا
سنحاول ان نقدم مجتمع افضل او توازن في
المجتمع بالنسبه لمن يتقدمون في السن طيب
المعروف انه اليوم هناك متطلبات متغيره في
السوق العمل وفي المستقبل العمل كيف تساهم
المبادره وكيف يمكنها ان تعزز مهارات
الشباب الباحثين عن فرنسا
كما قلنا هذه المنصه هي ليس فقط لفرص
العمل هي فرص نحو تحسين مستقبل هؤلاء
الشباب ومعنا في هذه المبادره شركاء من
اكاديميه معروفه ومرموقه في المنطقه
العربيه ستقدم فراسه التدريب التدريب سواء
العلمي او التدريب المهني مما يحضر هؤلاء
الشباب ليكونوا
بسير ذاتيه ومناسبه اكثر لمتطلبات السوق
العمل الحاليه والمستقبل
نحن نشكرك جزيلا الشكر منى فتاح كنت معنا
من بيروت